[Music]
you sent out a picture of Sofia
Vergara's but yes not - there it is
right there you creak look at that it is
sneaked up where she a Willett was she
willingly going along with this first I
just want to say you're welcome America
no she's actually really mad when I
really meant was thanks and then how
dare you yeah no she's great I mean I
said Sofia you know you mind if I take a
picture of your butt she's like Jess but
I have to see before you send it and so
you know she had full photo approval of
it what you don't know is that I also
took a picture of Ty Burrell but and
sent it out as well not as many views
yeah no thank you yeah so she was much
more her but was much more popular yeah
it's the most viewed picture on my
Twitter account ever it's just in okay
okay take it away take it just touch
coming back up its own accord are you
gonna move on to other okay are you
gonna move on to other Casper's yeah
yeah I might get Jesse Tyler Ferguson
sass up there at some point you know I
should show a picture of his butt nice
would you be interested in that any of
you not one person says yes pic milk
it's not often you hear things that
quiet